let's turn our attention now to the
press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive joining
me tonight the guardian's chief
political correspondent jessica algot
and the writer and journalist benedict
spence
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
well the eye shows her majesty's coffin
being driven into buckingham palace
their headline the queen returns home
similarly the express says home for one
last time
likewise the male home to her family
he's the son
welcome home ma'am
the telegraph calls the evening's events
the final homecoming
the mirror references the mobile phone
torches held aloft by mourners
describing the queen as led home by the
lights of love
the last night at the palace reads the
front of the times
the metro hears that the new prince of
wales and his brother the duke of sussex
will walk together in the procession
from the palace to westminster hall
where the queen will lie in state
away from rural matters the financial
times reports that government officials
have warned companies that it will take
longer for them to see the benefits of
the 150 billion pound energy support
package than it will for members of the
public
and the guardian understands that
restrictions around the sale and
promotion of junk food could be scrapped
now liz trust is prime minister
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
so welcome once again to jessica algot
and benedict spence thank you both for
coming in let's start off with the
express and uh their front page welcome
home
for one last time jessica
yeah and it's um
it felt like a lot of what we've seen
has been
you know the great sort of public
morning and this feels like a slightly
there's a slightly different tone to
everything tonight before the great kind
of ceremony of her lying in state
you know gets gets started over the next
few days um this is a private moment for
her with the family there's 22 members
of the family the first time they'll all
be together in that room
to to speak privately to to say their
own things to you know and their own
memories and if it i think that you can
see how grueling it's been you know as
well in people in people in grief over
the past few days so many public
ceremonies and
i i personally hope you know on a human
level they get a chance for you know
time to take a breath tonight
yes sir benedict they've hardly had time
to grief because it's been so public for
them yes i mean it's been very dignified
but almost sort of frenetic the fact
that it has been sort of up and down the
length of the country and i mean
obviously central london was very busy
today it's raining there's a lot of
people packed in obviously as you can
imagine and yet at the same time somehow
there was a certain stillness at the end
of it
uh when you know the procession sort of
made its way into buckingham palace
there does seem to be a sort of a
feeling of calm before it all sort of
gears up again for the next stage uh of
the proceedings and i think that that
you know what we often talk about you
know wanting to reflect on you know
times like this what is there to reflect
on i do think that this is just the
moment where the family can have that
sort of intake of breath for themselves
just between themselves and you know i
think that uh obviously that's going to
be very important for them because it is
emotionally it has already been pretty
difficult up to now and i can't imagine
it's going to get a lot easier over the
next week or so yes and our broad
correspondent random miles was
reflecting that uh tonight is that
private moment for the family before
tomorrow symbolically they hand her over
to the public and they're allowed to pay
their respects
yeah and and of course there are there
are so many people who kind of share in
a in a kind of public grief of uh you
know for what's happened for what the
monarch meant to them for the symbolism
she had for their in their lives but for
the people who are behind those doors
over there she she had a you know she
was a mother a grandmother or a great
grandmother um
and you know they will want to have
those you know to reminisce between
themselves about those very personal
private memories that they have of her
let's take a look at the mirror
and their headline led home by
lights we can just uh get that up and
that's in reference to
the mobile phones that people are
holding up the modern day candle if you
like which is uh quite useful because
it's it's raining and candles would have
been no use whatsoever quite nice in a
way there wasn't because everybody
always says these days people spend too
much time on their phone that they don't
recognize what's going on around them
well here we have a use actually that
was i think quite touching that's right
who would have thought actually that the
iphone could play you know quite a
touching role in such a sort of seismic
event but there you are
it is a a beautiful picture isn't it
jessica it is it will i'm not sure
whether it was with a spontaneous thing
was it something that just caught on in
the crowd i don't know whether you
whether you saw whether it was but i
think it's i mean it makes the pictures
you know look absolutely beautiful and i
think you know as well it's there's been
quite a lot of criticism i think about
if people hold you know obviously
wanting to watch things through their
cameras and
i sometimes think that's a bit
unjustified i think that people
like to feel like that at a moment in
history there's many people who will
never experience the sort of changeover
of a monarch and i think as well as
people obviously sharing in grief
there's a sense of wanting to be here to
witness history and i understand
you know why people might want to
capture that moment
benedict have you thought at any point
that it's been in in bad taste of when
people have sort of brought out their
mobile phones trying to capture
everybody does things in the uh in
different ways i mean i was here on the
evening uh that uh after her majesty uh
passed away and uh it was a very mixed i
think there were a lot of people who
didn't quite know how to behave there
were a lot of people just being very
quiet some people decided to play music
some people took selfies of themselves
looking sad
i don't know if that's a good taste or
if it's trying to you know sort of
project something if it's trying to send
a message
i do think actually you know i think
you're right everybody does it in their
own different way but because it's been
so long actually since we've been in
this sort of situation i think it is one
of those things where people genuinely
in that immediacy don't actually know
what is the correct thing to do and you
know if if you're yeah if you've not
been brought up in a culture where
you're very somber as today we are not
really quite so sombre as we used to be
at the time of the passing of the last
monarch um i think it can be quite
difficult uh to get the tone right but
broadly speaking actually i think people
have done it pretty well i wouldn't say
that there's been anything particularly
distasteful that's gone apart from the
odd protest here or there which of
course you know people are perfectly
inclined uh entitled to do
what have you made at the the the
process jessica the uh the protests and
i mean i i think that
there has to be
a really careful balance struck because
people you know have at their absolute
right to express those opinions
republicanism is a perfectly legitimate
point of view um that people should be
able to express
you would hope that people are able to
do that in a way that is not deeply
disrespectful to a grieving family but i
think that there are you know i i think
personally there's been some of the
policing of it has seemed on the face of
it to be over the top and and
counterproductive frankly because um the
last thing you want you know if you want
to establish legitimacy and as charles
you know has done you know pretty well
over the course of this last week
there's the polling shows that he
um you know his popularity is is pretty
good amongst the public in the way that
he's you know kind of conducted himself
over the past week then the last thing
you want to be
seen as doing is kind of crushing
dissent and um which will only spark
more you know people to to to try and
make their views known and i think that
i think it's deeply counter-productive
to try and
to try and you know squash those views
or those opinions uh benedict do you
think that the management of those who
wanted to protest has been heavy-handed
we saw the shots of that that uh
gentleman dragged out of the
crowd
i think that there have been a few
examples where you know that perhaps
that's down as much as anything to the
individual police officer deciding how
to respond in a certain certain
situation as i say i was here the
evening after it happened and there were
lots of people bearing in different ways
and actually i thought the police were
rather restrained um in how they handle
it because they had all comers you know
and it's you can't necessarily apply uh
blanket rules to a situation like that i
do think it's uh you know somebody
should have the ability to mourn their
own mother uh without being harassed i
do think that there is a line there to
be drawn but you know i don't really see
there's anything with holding a placard
say um and you know just making your
feelings hurt so you know it's often it
does come down to i think the judgment
of individual officers and actually it's
been a handful of cases it's not like
there have been mass demonstrations that
have been cracked on down by the police
so you know i think it would be wrong to
say that it started in a sort of spirit
of repression i think it's actually been
a rather british way of going about it
and saying well hang on anger you
shouldn't be behaving like that in some
circumstances and other police officers
going they're just they're just
expressing their views they're not
actually harming anybody let's just let
it slide
let's take a look at the telegraph now
they're headlined final
homecoming and that's been the
sentiment uh throughout that this this
is the final journey now it has been
described as such but uh
technically this literally is the final
journey and and obviously buckingham
palace is the home that so many people
associate with the queen or visitors of
you know visitors to london that's
that's the one where they you know where
children are told the queen lives when i
brought my little boy into town and you
know that's that's that's the place that
you that you point at and and of course
she always considers and as far as
as i understand it she always really
considered windsor to be like her proper
family home she had a great you know it
was the office yeah the office yeah yeah
and and that kind of that's that real
soft spot in our heart for balmoral and
and for sandringham but um you know it
feels like this is the the home that
everyone you know associates with her um
and you know you'll have that you know
there's always the story you tell
children that you know if the flag's
flying then it means the queen's in and
and you know it's flying
and certainly coming in this evening um
still people uh coming along to
buckingham palace tonight um you know
public transport was packed uh the rain
hasn't put anyone off at all i don't
think it's ever i don't think rain is
gonna put british people off um coming
through i've been coming to london for
anything let alone let alone the queen i
think that but uh yeah again coming home
to buckingham palace as you say it
wasn't really her home in that sort of
sense and again i think that there's a
certain poignancy there it's a gilded
cage in a lot of ways and this is the
final moments of the monarch we'll be
with her family but she is for the
nation she's not just for the family and
there is always going to be that sense
of no matter how much we talk about how
privileged the royal family is and of
course it is staggeringly privileged
there is that sort of sense of you'll
never just be a private citizen you'll
never just have those private moments
and when you do get them they will be
fleeting because even in death you'll be
taken away again for everybody else for
the nation actually to use as a rallying
point as much as anything else and i
think that that's worth pondering upon
jessica can you imagine how they're
feeling uh behind us this this last
private time with their their mother
grandmother
um as you say a family member not just
the the queen yeah and i'm sure that
it's it what it will be is a time for
you know a family that doesn't often get
to be in the same room together you know
that that often you know especially when
we get large extended families which the
queen had
um you know together to to to reminisce
privately about times that you know
we've never
you know private jokes we've never heard
or or you know memories from childhood
that sort of never made it into
newspaper pages or or onto into cameras
and that's a lovely moment i mean i'm
sure that there'll be a certain amount
of anxiety a certain amount of nerves
about the kind of public
you know the
the public duties that have got to be
performed over the next few days walking
in procession the funeral itself and you
know that some of that will be very
nerve-wracking i mean that the
descriptions of particularly what what
prince william and harry will have to do
over the next few days i mean the fact
that they're walking in procession
behind a coffin it was really very
evocative for those of us who watched
their mother's funeral and they when
they walked in the way they walked us as
boys and so i'm sure that there'll be
things
that that they'll be thinking about and
that it'll evoke in in us watching it
the times their their headline last
night at the palace uh sums it up
and i i just i just want to touch on
that point again actually the fact that
they're going to be walking in
procession behind the queen's coffin
that'll be i think particularly
heart-wrenching on a way that nobody
really is going to be able to understand
or empathize the worst thing about that
is that they will know that they're
going to have to do it again you know
when when sadly their their father uh
his time comes and that i think is
a rather twisted you know rather nasty
but not very nice thing at all to think
about that you you've had to go through
it as a boy you're going through it now
as men and it'll come again before you
yourself in the case uh prince william
ascend to the throne and i just i can't
really sort of begin to imagine what
that must feel like to know that you're
gonna have to do that in front of the
whole world you know repeating it over
and over again what a dreadful thought
that must be and that moves us to the
metro who
uh talking about that very uh procession
william and harry to walk together um
it's never going to be an easy thing but
obviously it's going to bring back so
many memories for them isn't it jessica
and i i mean i was
quite young when princess dana died but
that's the sort of moment that i
remember you know even as
you know quite a young child seeing her
you know seeing those two boys
you know walking behind you know their
mother their mother's funeral car and
it's it's of course that's what is going
to evoke for you know the public seeing
them together and knowing the kind of
tragedy of the way that the brothers
relationship has disintegrated which
they seem to now be you know it's
hopefully this is a moment for them to
try and heal that they they walked you
know they obviously they walked out
together to greet people
a few days earlier and they seem to be
incredibly determined to put on
a united front as much as that's
possible and i think that we'll you know
seeing it cast in a new light is is an
important i think it'll be an important
moment for people um but obviously you
know benedict was saying
you know almost torturous for the people
who have to do it yeah but but positive
um
story in the sense that they there seems
to be reconciliation um and that they
are
together as as siblings and and
wanting to be together we we read that
the prince of wales extended the olive
branch and and wanted to to make peace
and one hopes so too because you know
there is nothing actually worse when it
comes to a sort of big family reunion be
it a wedding or if you know whatever it
is and all wounds get opened up again
especially given that this is you know
being played out to the rest of the
world it was a little bit unsavory i
thought the way that you know there's
almost been this sort of anticipation of
what what will happen with megan and
harry and the rest of the family and you
sort of think
if there was one time i mean i don't
ever think particularly it's it's a good
moment to sort of rake that over the
coals slightly but actually if there was
one moment you shouldn't be thinking
about those things bringing this up it's
an event like this actually where there
are far more important things going on
so if there has been a reconciliation
even if there hasn't
i think the important thing is that they
are you know their action together as a
family and what goes on behind closed
doors i think actually
i think is for them and this this period
of all periods should not be a time for
you know certain you know media
organizations members of the public to
speculate on what might be going on
that's not for us at this point jessica
do you think some elements of the the
media have been mischief making because
some of the commentary was saying that
when they did go and walk about
the the couples were separated there was
distance between them
do you think that that's really not that
the sort of um
uh story that should be
discussed at this time as
benedict is suggesting i mean look i
think we live in a free country and
we've got a free press and you know
people are people are able to afford
their own views about what they what
what they see
um i'd be lying if i didn't find
generally some of the coverage about
both sides to be distasteful over the
course of the the the reporting of the
rows um but
i think
you know there is there is we live in an
age where every single instance of body
language captured on camera is kind of
reviewed on tick tock a million times
over with captions added to it and it's
you know this these mostly are generated
by members of the public rather than
than the media if anything you know
often the media kind of latches on to
what people on online are saying so i
think i think that that was probably
quite inevitable and of course there was
a kind of
fascination i think particularly with
with megan and sometimes an unfair one
um but you know i think by and large
what they have there has been a real
effort you know no matter whether there
really has been any kind of
reconciliation behind
closed doors to show a united front and
to do you know to do the duty that they
have to to their grandmother
okay let's move away from
the
queen's
funeral upcoming funeral and let's have
a look at the financial times uh their
story their companies won't get energy
benefits as soon as the public that's
the the prediction
their benedict i think this is down to
the fact that this will require
legislation that there isn't actually a
system in place for businesses as there
is for households with the energy cap
and i think that that's why it's going
to take a little bit longer and of
course the problem is that with events
like this and you know a lot of things
shutting down and also party conference
season about to happen there is a
question as to when it is that actually
the legislation could be put before
parliament and subsequently passed and i
think that there is probably a good
argument at this point given the
extraordinary circumstances for uh
canning party conferences and i'm sure
that won't go down particularly well
with the parties themselves but you have
to be thinking about the best interests
of the nation it's all very well uh
trying to put in place energy caps uh
for households if we're all gonna come
out of this in six months time and
there's hardly going to be an economy
left because lots of businesses have
folded nothing even to do with you know
a rising heat or anything like that they
just can't afford to pay for the energy
that they need uh so this is the other
thing to remember this isn't just you
know about businesses it's things like
charities i think it actually affects
things like schools as well
you might want to correct me if i'm
wrong on that it's public services as
well so you know we've all been talking
haven't we about oh xyz many people
won't be able to heat their houses this
winter and you're kind of thinking well
people might not be able to go into work
you know after winter unless this is
sort of nipped in the bud and you know i
feel a little bit more animated about
this because this is a very this is a
very serious emergency if it comes to
pass the situation that is being
predicted by many it is going to be
catastrophic for very many businesses in
this country and that will lead to just
elongating the pain out over the course
of the rest of this parliament which if
you're a liz trust you don't have that
much time left before we get to the
general election cycle and then you
really are staring down the barrel
so can the party conferences and get on
with the business at hand
i think that there's a there's a good
argument for party conferences going
ahead and a good argument for parliament
to sit while they happen that happened
in 2019 during the high the brexit
crisis there's no need for all mps to be
at party conferences they can spend a
day or so there if they want and for
parliament to sit during that that part
you know that part of it and i think
that that would be a reasonable solution
to the to the crisis and you know the
crisis that we face and and it's not
unprecedented for that to happen and
indeed i think it's likely that some
some form of that probably will happen
or at least that that conference recess
will be curtailed in some way i mean i
think with the when it comes to the the
energy but package for businesses and
the blunt truth is it's just not ready
and that was obvious on thursday when it
was presented to us that they they just
they all they could talk about really
all the treasure we could talk about was
an equivalent package for business which
didn't sound like a fully formed plan so
i think that it's just going to take
some time to develop how you make a
similar kind of offer to our from
households to businesses yeah slacking
on on detail i think is how you describe
that we've just got time for the
guardian very quickly and this is um the
story to do with junk food rules um
could be scrapped under this trust i
mean this is proper liz trust stuff
everybody's talking about how she's a
darling of the free market think tank
circle and this is the sort of thing
that they talk about very long time is
uh you know the
intervening the nanny states all this
and the other the idea of course behind
this that you know things like uh the
ban on adverts you know having uh suites
at the checkout buy one get one free
offers all of these things could be
scrapped because it's about trying to
reduce the pressures on business and i
think that there is actually an argument
about that in the short term you want to
get business you want to give them every
advantage that they can but we do need
to be honest about this this does mean
that it's a trade-off it's about
long-term health uh but yeah of of of
the nation i think probably in the
circumstances list trust would say look
i don't have time to be thinking about
you know people's obesity 20 30 years
down the line this is about personal
responsibility and right now i have
responsibility to businesses benedict
and jessica thank you so much for the
moment in the next down